Slaying zombies, directing movies,
and looking fab. Dani is all grown up
and still showin' up. Forever and ever.
Watching the 1993 film "Hocus Pocus" is
a requisite on Halloween. Not only is the
movie full of spooky fun, but it also
has plenty of heart. One of the film's
most endearing characters is Dani, portrayed by
Thora Birch, the little sister of Max Dennison.
"Boo!"
"Dani!"
"I scared you. I scared you. Ah ha ha ha ha."
In the film, Max begrudgingly goes
trick-or-treating with his sister and
they end up at the Sanderson sisters' home,
where complete chaos ensues. With the help
of the child-turned-black cat, Thackery Binx,
the zombie "Billy" Butcherson, and Max's crush,
Allison, the siblings manage to escape
their encounter with the witches unscathed.
During an October 2018 interview with People
magazine, the film's director Kenny Ortega briefly
spoke about Thora Birch's performance as Dani
and couldn't stop gushing about her performance.
"Thora Birch. One of the brightest
young children that, to this day
that I've ever worked with. I mean
she was so ahead of the class."
Birch also discussed her experience working
on "Hocus Pocus" while speaking to Access
in October 2018. Birch shared that she understood
the significance of acting alongside Bette Midler.
"No, I was so excited. I mean, working with
her was like working with an idol of yours."
After "Hocus Pocus" premiered, Thora Birch
appeared in a number of notable films including
"Now and Then," "American Beauty," and "Ghost
World." In 2019, the actor began playing Mary
on the hit AMC show "The Walking Dead," though,
as fans are aware, her character was relegated
entirely to the show's tenth season.
While speaking to KTLA 5 in October 2019,
Birch revealed that she was not familiar with "The
Walking Dead" prior to joining the series' cast.
"I hadn't watched the show
before I started Season 10,
but I went down the rabbit hole immediately and
started like you know, just jamming the seasons."
The actor then revealed that she found it
difficult to shoot the series due to the
Atlanta heat – where the show is filmed – but
found the experience rewarding nonetheless.
"It's a blast because you get to do so many
types of things that normally you don't do."
Since her "Walking Dead" stint, Thora Birch
has only appeared in two subsequent roles:
the lead in Oklahoma tornado film "13
Minutes," and as the star of narrative
podcast "Overleaper." She's currently
slated to appear in a TV movie based
on the real-life story of Gabby Petito — which
she's also directing — as well as the Wednesday
Adams TV series "Wednesday." That said, Birch
left "Wednesday" midway into its production.
Since she remains credited on six episodes
of the series online, however, it's possible
that the show's producers will indeed make use of
some of what Birch filmed during her time on-set.
But even if she doesn't show up in
"Wednesday," you can always relive
her early career-defining performance
as Dani Dennison in "Hocus Pocus."
"It's been great fun, but
I guess I better be going."
"Oh, stay for supper."